نحن الان في مدينه وادي حلفا وهذا هو مقر
اللجنه الوسيطه التي كلفت باستلام جوازات
المواطنين السودانيين للحصول على التاشيره
المصريه تمهيدا لسفرهم عبر احدى المعابر
معبر اشكيت او معبر اركين طبعا يظهر هذا
الزحام بسبب تكدس الكثير من المسافرين
الفارين من جحيم المعارك المستمره حتى هذه
اللحظه في الخرطوم حيث اكبر من الطاقه
الاستيعابيه لهذه المدينه الصغيره هنا
تقريبا
المئات من المسافرين الذين قدموا جوازاتهم
لهذه اللجنه التي بدورها ستقدمها للقنصليه
المصريه للحصول على تاشيره طبعا الجوازات
السودانيه لمن هم اكبر من 16 عاما وحتى 50
عاما يحتاجون الى تاشيره مسبقه وبالتالي
لابد من ان يتقدموا للحصول على تاشيره
مسبقه للسفر الى مصر وهنا يتم تقديم هذه
الجوازات لهذه اللجنه الوسيطه المكلفه
باستلام الجوازات تمهيدا لتقديمها للجنه
للقوسيه المصريه هنا يتم الان الفرز بعض
الجوازات لاستلام المسافرين الذين تم
التاشير لهم للحصول لكن بحسب الكثير من
الذين صدقنا اراءهم هنا بسبب الزحام
فالعمل يمشي ببطء هنا اكثر من تاشيرات
جوازات تقدر بحوالي 3000 جواز لكن ما يسلم
بشكل يومي هو تقريبا ما بين 100 او 200
جواز وهذا بسبب ازدحام الكبير في هذه
المدينه الصغيره وايضا بسبب الطاقه
الاستيعابيه التي تفوق الاجراءات المتبعه
بشكل عادي في هذه الايام حسن الرزاق
الجزيره من مدينه وادي حلفا